if you were me would you rather live in
legrand or
new york city that happened to love
lagrange so uh-uh what does legrand have
exactly nothing what does new york city
have it has
broadway and gaga yeah lady gaga
don't do it don't do what listen to me
when i say
you're beautiful in your way cause god
makes no mistakes
i'm on the right track baby i was born
this way
excuse me i didn't know you knew the
words don't hide yourself from regret
just love yourself and you're set
i'm on the right track baby i was born
this way all right we're not doing that
again
[Music]
hey dad can i talk to you for a minute
i'm getting picked on by these guys at
school
why is that because i'm not like that
there's got to be more than that why are
you like that cause
i'm different that's not an answer jaden
cause i'm gay
we're gonna let nature take its course
all right it'll work itself out no
what it's not gonna work itself
[Music]
to muster up the courage to ask for
[Music]
room help jayden knew before he died
that you loved him and accept them
that's what matters i never let him know
it was okay i gotta live with that
i have been to the movies i decided to
walk
across america i'll talk to anybody who
listens about bullying when i told you
to take a walk i met around the block
not to new york city
he told us he won't live there someday
remember
[Music]
i saw he's right there in front of me
god queens are everywhere now can we
turn that off
that wasn't even an appetizer but i have
to deal with day in and day out well
that's because you were in everybody's
face about it i wonder where i got that
one from
there's a lot of things i've learned out
here but nobody but me for company
i still feel jaden's presence
i still got a long road ahead of me
you